this is lion 3 straight-to-video I love
how they name in the episode the lion
like lion - lion 3 is that you're really
funny um and again no Rob like I said
next couple he'll probably be out of but
man of all the ones to miss yep another
uh another big laid out a lot of
information um but but also very
emotional very nice it starts off with
um Steven just sort of messing around
with his lion and oh I'm forgetting her
name
it's a Sadie yeah Sadie uh talking about
how her mom always makes her watches and
she's kind of sick of it and stuff while
they were looking for some to eat so
whatever they're goofing around and
stuff and then uh Steven has a dream
that he can't breathe and he doesn't
know why is in this pink land and
entrance I was just lying on top of Mt
hee ha ha and then we find out that
pearl likes to watch Steven sleep seeing
how Steven's just a kid he's like oh ok
weird just go away and I don't think he
realizes quite how weird that is
um but once again he falls asleep and
wakes up in this pink world and it turns
out it's the lion's mane there's like
this whole entire world in the lion's
mane and he tries to go in there he goes
into the mane and he discovers a few
things there he discovers uh like a
guitar he discovers this VHS that says
for Steven um he discovers this mr.
universe sure those probably his dad's
and then he also discovers uh we don't
know what it is it's Canada's bubbled
upside down pyramid something like that
a lot say we've seen something like that
before the pyramid but maybe not um and
he takes the VHS goes watches it with uh
was Eddie and the stateís and again I'm
sorry from you know terrible I am with
names but and with turning my phone off
shame on me um so yeah I pretty much
watches this video and it's a video of
Steven's mom talking about ice she's
filming it for Steven first time we see
the mother I think it's the first time
they reveal that picture they show all
of it anyway and we see that the
watch my caught that the video is
actually sort of an introduction to
Stephen while she's still pregnant with
him and that the fathers they're just
playing the guitar and stuff we don't
even know if he knows what we're about
to find out which is that when Stephen
is born she can't exist she becomes half
of Stephen I guess it's how gems work I
suppose and so now we figure out what
happened to her uh and it's interesting
you know did Stephen know that did even
the gems know that um you know I'm not
sure because Stephen doesn't show the
video to the other gems um he decides to
source Niek away which I kind of like I
like there's almost served like this
little bit of separation happening
between him and the gems um which I
would kind of get to after all the stuff
that's happened and kind of how
aggressive they can be so yeah so he
goes we find out that it's hat you know
that that he's pretty much half of him
is the mother pretty much and she says
that you know the stuff you'd expect you
know that she loves him and that you
know a time you feel good about yourself
are wonderful that's gonna be her and
she does a star wipe on the video which
is interesting I at first I really laugh
because I'm like oh my gosh at the end
of the the episode is like no there's
more but then that gets me thinking how
much is like it's all of us being
watched by somebody because they all end
with the star wipes so who knows um and
even the button like you know he says
push the stop button now let's see what
this doesn't like this little line of
like rainbows and stars goes by and it's
like did did cameras back then even
those old cameras have like those
operations you know where it can do
those kind of weird wipes and stuff like
that or was that just like something
magical that happened right there and
it's like no I'll be a big thing in
another episode or maybe it's just a
rainbow wipe who knows um and yeah but
kind of makes me wonder why is somebody
watching this or these kind of like
where these all can be filmed and they
all end with the star wipe or something
I don't know probably thinking too deep
into it um and then afterwards uh both
imitated
watching the video he goes home he
thanks lion and then she calls up her
mom and says that she's actually
thankful for making the lunches it's
very very sweet very very nice I'm gonna
call my mom right after this day um but
uh yeah so I like these episodes that
can combine sort of the you know they
can do a lot of exposition and reveal
more of the mystery but they're very
heartfelt and they're very loving and
this one felt like a really good gel of
the two um especially like when he would
he would fall asleep and wake up you
know in the lion's mane and he would
think it's part of the dream and it
would keep happening and they realize
it's not dreaming but then there's that
nice little touch on a tool of him
having to hold his breath when going in
like he can't breathe in the main even
though there appears to be sky and
everything else there uh and it's also
very obvious the lion knows Stephen
however at least know Stephens mom
obviously and proudly recognizes Stephen
now as the mother so you know I think
he's either trying to help explain
things or you know maybe for him it's
just like no no it's time to do this
you'll always do this right you know
Stephens mother come on yeah go on the
main it's time to go on the main again
so uh although it has a feel of like it
has a feel like he's trying to teach him
you know trying to teach him that this
is your path this is your route and
everything uh and particularly at when
time is right scenarios because why
doesn't you just do all this stuff I
mean II just serve sits around and
sleeps and does whatever um so yeah so
that's that's an interesting development
now knowing that Stephen is half the
mother um you know okay I like whatever
been reincarnated or earth just in the
gem or bow ever this all works uh I
don't know man the whole pearl watching
him sleep and everything it's just I'm
I'm feeling like the evidence is piling
up man I I think they have thing all
right I think at least uh she had she
had pearl either had like a crush or she
had like some kind of connection
uh two rows I think um you know we don't
know what it is but I say if she would
watch Stephen while he sleeps
you know that's that's in trance she was
embarrassed to reveal it as well it
wasn't like oh I was just watching you
to see if anything happens when you
sleep or something like that though
maybe maybe that's something too maybe
when Rose slept something happened you
know we don't know entirely how the gems
work uh so maybe she's watching hoping
something will happen or maybe she just
likes watching Stephen sleep because it
reminds her a lot of Rose that's what
I'm feeling the direction the show
usually goes is usually the the very
affectionate ones and then the ones they
have very nice feelings to it and stuff
so I'm assuming it's heading that
direction but I don't know um you know I
don't know if this game out before or
after coral uh so we don't know if this
is like something that can happen yet or
not or if they're just very strongly
hinting at it so um yeah but I don't
know that's a that that's there's like a
million clues pointing to this so either
they're building up this one thing and
it's just like haha we actually did this
the whole time but knowing the show and
how much they really sort of like these
relationships and these connections and
stuff like that that's the guess I'm
going with um so again I sort of the few
episodes I've seen again I'll point them
out when I see them uh the show does I
say two million times but it really does
interesting things with identity and if
that is the route they're going I think
that'd be like a fascinating route
that'd be a really interesting route um
you know because you could argue stuff
about reincarnation or even taking that
out just how much of a person is passed
on to the child
how much is nature and nurture and stuff
so I think there's a lot you can do with
that so yeah it's a it's a big reveal
it's a nice emotional episode it's an
interesting direction that it's taking
and I like it I really like the
direction it's going and it's again when
you have sort of like this big bomb like
that dropped it's exciting when it's not
like oh now that's answered you because
you can do that you can have something
it's like oh now that's answered
we know this but the plus like the real
sugar on top is now what can we do with
this what other additional things can we
do with this information and going back
now what can we learn about these
characters in past episodes knowing this
information so now I'm really really
curious I like that's just all the more
fascinating um so yeah that's about it
really really good episode definitely
really enjoy it nice to finally see what
Stephens mom looks like as well and uh
yeah I think that's about it for this
one I will see you at the next one
Lena